foreign
right now it's time for some social
media questions you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalists
in Alabama we got a question from
Facebook Victor asks how do I minimize
my old journals sketch pads notebooks
pens and pencils I've tried so many
times and I just can't let them go help
help just send them to me I'll take care
of them for you I got this one guys uh
Victor what is the sound of one hand
clapping
Ryan can show you
it's not very loud
are a little too prepared for that
I'm still not from the substance that's
Bart Simpson it kind of sounds like
Ryan's masturbating into the mic
[Laughter]
I feel like Raya read a book of coins
saw that one and just like spent the
hour figuring out I've been waiting to
use that for like 25 years since I saw
that Simpsons episode
Victor I got stuff the pithy for you we
call these minimal maxims we put them in
the show notes well podcast Sean tweezed
them out the minimalists.com podcast to
find the show notes to all of our
episodes the only way to let go
is to stop clinging and that's what I
wanted to talk to you about today
because we're talking about letting go
but really the only way to do it is to
stop clinging you remember when he
deleted all my notes what
I thought I was letting go not deleting
other people's stuff no it was funny so
won't let this go
no I had like I don't know essay ideas
song lyrics jokes I don't know like the
you know all these ideas that I was
clearly Clinging On to because I had you
know 42 separate notes that wow
um well it was kind of what we were
talking about in the first question like
I didn't really even know they were
there until I started going through them
I'm like oh yeah one day I'm gonna use
this you know so Josh um and his uh uh
you know benevolent self was like hey
man I'm gonna show you how to get your
notes on iCloud so he long story short
deleted all my notes and got me on
iCloud thanks man I appreciate that but
at first I was like I had this twinship
like no like I know there's like at
least
and my brain is like there's at least
three of those things I know I wanted
it reminds me last time that I upgraded
my computer uh the one that was
available you ordered it for me it
didn't have enough uh hard drive space
right and it was that was an exercise
for me in letting go because I tried to
do the whole transfer it and it was like
an hour in it was like oh this hard
drive is full and it can't transfer
everything you would think the software
would be able to read that at first yeah
anyway anyway I get to this point and
it's just like so you can choose to exit
and basically go back to the factory
setting so I just started with factory
settings wow and I didn't bring anything
over not a thing from my previous
computer not an essay no photos nothing
was brought over from the previous
device and it was so freeing it was as
you said terrifying at first because
it's like oh no wait wait but then I
realized something that was really
important everything well here's a
better way to put it
you strangle everything
that you cling to and I would even say
that you strangle everyone that you
cling to as well so this doesn't just
apply to stuff but you strangle
everything that you're clinging to if
you're holding on to a bunch of stuff
including these sketch pads and
notebooks and pins and old journals and
pencils whatever you're holding on to
you start to strangle you strangle the
usefulness out of them you strangle the
creativity out of your own life and if
you're doing this with a person in your
life a lover a friend Etc you're
clinging to them you're strangling the
Vitality out of the relationship
when you're clean all the time you're a
walking True Crime
don't tweet that podcast
oh man you know the closest thing I have
to this is my old calculus notes
remember how hard we worked in our
calculus course Josh I remember how hard
I worked
dude we worked really hard like learning
the quadratic formula and the flipping
and forget it and like all the different
and I had all these notes and I love
math that's the thing like I really
enjoy understanding like the Nuance uh
so I'm holding on to these notes
thinking that one day I'm gonna need
these
in case in case I'm interested in going
back and uh looking at the Nuance of
calculus like not even considering the
fact that I could just look it up online
but regardless
um yeah I I thought about scanning them
and then I'm like what am I doing man
I'm getting rid of these so if you're
holding on all your journals and all
like why are you holding on to this
because you're trying to preserve
something then great you can preserve it
there are you don't have to scan it
yourself there are uh companies you can
pay to scan it for you and they'll get
rid of your your notes for you so you
don't even have to get those journals
back they'll just send you scanned pages
of it and that's really where uh you
know if this is causing Victor some
stress that's really where he's got to
look at like all right what are these
journals pencils pens so forth and so on
what are these doing for me are they
causing you Joy or are they causing you
stress sounds like they're causing you
stress so now the next thing is like all
right so how are you gonna how are you
gonna get rid of the of this stress you
look into scanning it maybe you look at
it you're like that's too much money I'm
not willing to spend that money on it
well then you're probably not willing to
hold on to your notebooks then you know
yeah so sometimes in in the comments
people react to these kinds of ideas by
by saying you guys are trying to make me
throw away my stuff right because we
give a lot of arguments for why you
ought to question this and why you
should reconsider that and and then
people go to defending their right to
hang on to things well I'm going to keep
this because it brings me joy in this
way and it brings me joy in that way and
the thing I want people to understand is
we are not fighting to get you to give
away anything that you want to keep
we're fighting for you to fight for the
things that you want to keep by actually
using them by actually utilizing them in
a way that brings you the joy you say
they have the potential to bring what's
deadly is not hanging on to something
what's deadly is telling yourself a
story about how something brings you Joy
and then betraying that very Story by
burying it in a coffin never looking at
it again until it's time to move and you
got to pay a couple of hundred dollars
for some extra cubic feet that's no way
to live if you want the stuff keep the
stuff but if you're going to keep the
stuff fight to use it for the reasons
that reflect that Joy you felt when you
bought it did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free